So the self-inflicted debt damage for Donald
Trump continues to be done.
The doctor who developed the Montreal cognitive
assessment, that's the so-called test that
Trump took and claims he aced.
The doctor that created that test has come
out and said, listen, this is supposed to
be an easy test.
It's really just meant to screen out relatively
serious cognitive decline.
And remember that this is now relevant again,
because in Donald Trump's bizarre interview
with Fox News host Chris Wallace over the
weekend, Trump talked about how he aced the
test.
Joe Biden couldn't do well on the test.
Trump said.
Trump said the last five questions are really
tough.
And at one point when Chris Wallace said they're
not really tough.
Trump accused Chris Wallace of being unable
to answer some of the questions.
It was completely outrageous as far as a thing
to say.
But more importantly, the real story here
is we're now hearing as we hear from the doctor
who developed the test.
The story is that Trump found some of the
questions difficult.
That's really the red flag.
Here's a reminder of what Donald Trump said
before we get to what the doctor has now said,
people who is more competent, who's got his
mind to sounder.
I've made beats.
You won.
Well, I tell you what.
Let's take a test.
Let's take a test right now.
Let's go down.
Joe and I will take a test.
Let him take the same test that I took.
Incidentally, I took the test, too, when I
heard that you passed it.
Yeah.
How did you do?
Well, it's not the hardest task now, but the
last picture is in Alaska and it's an L.A.
Naida.
I guess, you see, that's all misrepresenting.
That's what it was on the Web.
So I'll misrepresentation because, yes, the
first two questions are easy, but I'll bet
you couldn't even answer the last five questions.
I'll bet you when they get very hard.
The last five.
Well, one of them was cut back from 100 by
seven.
And let me tell you, not you couldn't answer
if you couldn't answer.
All right.
Across many of the questions, I get you the
test.
I'd like to give it, but I guarantee you the
Joe Biden could not answer those questions.
OK.
And I answered all 35 questions.
Correct.
So Trump said the first few questions are
easy, but I bet you couldn't even answer the
last five questions.
They get very hard.
Now, it is strange.
This is a test again meant to screen out relatively
serious cognitive decline.
It's weird, but by saying Chris Wallace couldn't
answer the last five questions, he's essentially
saying he believes Chris Wallace is suffering
from cognitive decline.
Now, this entire portion of the interview
is crazy also because the test doesn't have
35 questions, although it's based on a maximum
score of 30 points.
It doesn't have thirty five questions.
And that's sort of a weird thing for Trump
to say.
It is also crazy for Trump to say Chris Wallace
couldn't get the questions right.
But now we have heard from Dr. Ziad Nasrudin
who developed this test.
And Dr. Nasra, Dean is now speaking out and
saying, listen, you know, this this talk about
tough questions doesn't make any sense.
This test is supposed to be really easy for
anyone who's not cognitively impaired.
Trump talked about acing the test like it's
some kind of an accomplishment.
When he spoke to Hannity, I believe it was
last week.
Remember this one?
He did mean that because he hasn't taken any
cognitive test, because he couldn't pass one.
I actually took one when a very recently when
I when I was, you know, the radical left was
saying is, you all there is you all there.
And I proved that was all there because I
wasted I aced the test that he should take
the same exact tests.
The very standard tests I took took it at
Walter Reed Medical Center in front of doctors.
And they were very surprised.
They said that's an unbelievable thing.
Rarely does anybody do what you just did.
But he should take that same test.
But now he has been totally taken over, aced
the test.
I mean, this is ridiculous.
And Dr. Ziad Nasrudin said to MarketWatch
that, quote, This is not an IQ test or the
level of how a person is extremely skilled
or not.
The test is supposed to help physicians detect
early signs of Alzheimer's.
And it became very popular because it was
a short test and very sensitive for early
impairment.
The normal score, according to Dr. Nasrudin,
is 27 out of 30.
The toughest part is being given five words
and then being asked to recall them after
five minutes.
And then I believe it's like after ten minutes.
And when you're in the middle of taking a
test, this is the point.
That part is sometimes the one that's tougher
for people even not suffering from cognitive
impairment.
But beyond that, this is an easy test where
the normal score is almost perfect.
The test cannot determine if somebody is smart.
The tests cannot determine if somebody has
a high level of ability.
And when Trump said, you know, doctors were
shocked, they had never seen someone do what
I did on this test.
It's outrageous and it's laughable.
So the big takeaways here are Trump said that
the questions get tough at the end.
That's not true.
That's a concern.
Number two, Trump said he recently took it.
We've not been told that Trump took this test
since 2018 as far as we knew.
Trump took the Montreal cognitive assessment
in 2018.
So if Trump was again tested recently, it
would be worth knowing why, where and what
the circumstances were, because that's not
actually been revealed.
And number two, again, Trump talks about 35
questions in the last few are hard.
If he's talking about this test, that's a
real problem.
If he was given some other test, then that
would also be important for the public to
know.
And then lastly, maybe most importantly, Trump
doesn't understand the nature of this test.
Like when he talks about acing it and impressing
doctors, this is a test where unless you're
suffering from cognitive decline, you do really
well on it.
It's not that doctors would go, wow, wow,
you really did.
It's you know, it turns out that that that
you're not actually suffering from cognitive
decline.
We're so impressed with you, Mr. President.
That's weird.
And that's another question.
Now, the other thing is people don't even
typically take this test unless there's a
question about their cognitive ability.
Now, maybe because of all of the things swirling
around Trump.
Trump looked for a test to take.
But it also shouldn't be ignored that in normal
circumstances, this is a test that a physician
would suggest.
If they have some reason to think it's important
to screen out cognitive decline, who knows?
Every aspect of this just stinks to high heaven.
And as usual, Trump's discussions of the tests
only raise more questions.
How many questions are on it?
Why did Trump find them tough?
Which test did he take?
Who administered it?
When did he take it?
Why hasn't it been mentioned?
Or is he talking about 2018?
I don't know that we're going to get answers
to these questions, but the important thing
is we don't really need any answers to these
questions to know he has to be voted out in
just over three months.
That part is clear.
And that's what's making this increasingly
simple for more and more voters, at least
the ones that I'm hearing from every day.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Also, remember to get the daily audio podcast
on your favorite podcasting app, whether it's
Stitcher I, iTunes, Google Play, Pandora,
Spotify, we're on all of them.
Get that daily podcast every single day.
Usually around three
is
when
it's out.